the Ford Fiesta never has more advanced
engineering gone into a small car it's
the end of an era well several the Ford
Fiesta it's a very Advanced baby
the Ford Fiesta has survived and thrived
across almost five decades becoming the
UK's most popular car okay so this is
Molly
I'm eating Fiesta monthly
and Martin blue were the very first came
off
so news that it's being discontinued
next summer was not welcomed by the many
Fiesta drivers and admirers like Gary
Wilson the owner of Molly the fiesta
very first meet she was Dusty unpolished
unloved just being brought back up from
England and the reaction she got was
absolutely fantastic so it just made the
Overflow you know it was I thought yeah
I need to keep this card but my son now
he's 14 he wants to take that ticket on
when he's older the fiesta was
originally released in the UK in 1976
and cost
1856 pounds almost 10 000 pounds in
today's money these days prices begin at
around 18 000 pounds over 46 years there
have been eight different generations of
the super mini with 4.8 million sold in
the UK there's a big sense of nostalgia
when it comes to the fiesta and many of
those who'll miss seeing it around had
one as their first set of wheels well
all after just have this little tier of
this cry today remember our first laugh
that first kiss that first drive in a
full Fiesta and think about what Falcon
offer us in the future Ford says all its
cars will be fully electric by 2030 but
not this much-loved model a big
disappointment for the owner of Freddie
the fiesta Freya Hallam this was her
first car just two years ago so
obviously last year when all the fuel
prices went a lot higher it wasn't that
economical for me traveling to work
every day but um so I went and got
another one that was more economical but
yeah I just I would love to drive this
again at some point and you don't want
to sell it despite the fact that you
could make some money out of it it's
just a lovely car I just can't bear to
see anyone else driving and now freya's
even more determined to hold on to
Freddy into his old age one of the many
Fiesta owners past and present who
aren't ready to say goodbye to this car
Becky Cottrell Sky News Swindon